coming out of this pandemic which we're
still sort of in
a lot of people were left
leaning on social media as sort of this
way to connect with people or zoom
to just keep them motivated when you've
talked about being in a dark space and
questioning if this is something that
you even wanted to do being hollywood
comedy acting
how have you been able to push through
that
and why do you think it is so important
to share your stories your struggle with
the general public
i was able to push through that
by one i have
a great therapist
um
who really on a basic level just brought
things down to a basic level like
sometimes it just feels like things are
so chaotic and hectic and crazy in your
head they they start to loom like a
mountain that is so daunting and you
start to feel like there's no way i'm
going to be able to get to the top of
that and what
what i feel like a good therapist does
is they are able to just level that
mountain down to a molehill for you
and
you know she
she took what felt like this craziness
and just made it like no you just got to
get confident again and you're like
oh and even that word again is like well
i was i've had i've been confident
before right so there's hope
in knowing that i've been
the place that i want to go
i think um
there was also just a support system of
friends
that
were
willing to listen where do you see
yourself in five years i know you have
things in the works right now that you
said aren't quite you know the ink isn't
dry but where do you see yourself
in five years i want to see
my creative work on bigger platforms
that are reaching more people and i know
that may seem very like generic but as a
diy person that's a big deal because it
means for those who don't know what diy
is do it yourself
and you can't do that completely
yourself so it does require a certain
level of like
trust and giving over to get into these
other spaces and you know people say you
got to play the game you got to play the
game and i just
do you think that's what makes you
different
so different than a lot of other people
here in hollywood
yes because i have no interest in
playing the game i want to change the
game
and
it's not to say that i'm expecting to
like do some big overhaul of that snazz
but i would love to carve a path that
lets others like me understand that they
don't have to
succumb to certain behaviors in order to
see success
patreon that's something that you move
to yeah it's a safe space
patreon people are there and they pay a
small fee
but they're there because they want to
be there to support you and that's a
completely different environment to be
sharing and to be giving your thoughts
in and creating content in than the
wilds of social media where so many
people
are not there with support they're there
to troll they're there to be contrary
you know and it's just it begins to feel
like less of a
creative space and more of like a
battlefield so being able to come over
to patreon also allows me to create
independent work that is supported
financially right because i do like to
create content as a diy person
you know if you're trying to write a
scripted show that's taking you two
years right to do that you know there's
i have a musical that i wrote where i
took wu-tang records and turned them
into jazz and i'm about to bring that to
the screen i i have smartphone and black
that's gonna be a special on screen you
know i have scripted projects that i'm
working on i have an audible project
that i'm working on like all of these
things take
so much time
but you still want to like
give
to the folks in real time and so it
allows you to balance those things right
having reached this level
knowing you want to do even more what is
it that keeps you grounded that that
keeps you happy keeps you at peace
i mean
i really really love watching tv
it's so it's very basic okay like
i really really were looking for a very
profound answer like
tv and candy corn
tv candy corn playing candy crush
like
sitting there with my boo and my dog
like
that really does bring me peace in my
creative space i would say i'm at my
happiest when i'm on stage i just i love
the stage
it's my home
and it really just
connecting with audiences and hearing an
audience sing your favorite songs with
you is like i could tell you were having
a great time in harlem it is
i it always amazes me how many people
get the same joy from things that bring
me joy so when we're able to do that
together on stage it's just like it's
incredible